did you walk down the aisle yes I can't
please tell me you have videos of this
but I blacked out I actually don't
remember those Kourtney Kardashian
confesses she was blackout drunk during
her unofficial ideas to Travis Barker I
guess what happens in Vegas doesn't
always stay in Vegas yeah remember when
kravis tied the knot after the Grammys
in April you did a practice run on the
wedding congratulations thank you well
Court chats with her pal Simon Huck on
the latest episode of the famous
family's Hulu series and dishes on that
late night ceremony or at least what she
can remember of it we knew that Elvis
had to marry us it was the only one open
at that hour nobody was around like it
was security his manager and then my
drum Tech he's like a photographer did
you walk down the aisle yes you can
please tell me about videos of this but
I blacked out I actually don't remember
them
I didn't even remember Elvis like saying
to me walking down the aisle I just
didn't remember I didn't remember I had
a bouquet the bouquet on the floor after
that they went took the fresh roses out
front and did the bouquet toss
Ed E.T chatted with the owner of the
little chapel and he said that whole
Elvis officiant thing
the lovebirds uh about 12 30 on I guess
Monday morning I got a call that a
celebrity wanted to get married and they
didn't tell me who it was they just said
it's a celebrity and we need else when
Elvis was marrying us he's like I Chloe
take the Travis and I just like lost my
mind fell straight on the floor and we
like couldn't get up no you guys Court
was on one it was so good well tequila
tequila Courtney is a good person yeah
it is a it's a whole thing she is her
own person they were just fun in love
they were just kissing and laughing it's
fun it's funny they're in love
and they're just smiling
I did throw up after though and took my
top off and unbuttoned my pants and I
had to like walk back through the hotel
with a million people taking my photo I
was a hot slob Kebab we did try to get a
license but they wouldn't give us the
certificate it was 2 am and I'm sure we
probably could have got a license the
next day but what could be a more fun
night in Vegas I am truly living my best
life
don't let anyone tell you any different
this went on to tie the knot in an
official wedding in Italy in May and
it's a good thing they did because
Court's bombed your Kris Jenner didn't
want to miss it I'm not gonna lie it
would be so disappointing if Courtney
really got married in Vegas and I wasn't
there
but
I guess I'll get over it I mean been
there done that Kim did it too she
didn't even tell me when she came home
because she was afraid yeah yeah I'd be
afraid of me too yeah exactly I mean
it's fun I think that they would have
had they gotten a permit I mean what
does it really mean she was drunk as a
skunk laying on the floor throwing up
who wants to get married like that who
doesn't just kidding I was sexy yeah
totally
[Music]